the entire donald trump paid off a porn
star after having an affair with her
while or just after his wife had given
birth to their sons story as i like to
call it concisely was blown wide open
yesterday i told you previously that
donald trump's lawyer michael cohen went
public and he admitted that yeah
porn star stormy Daniels did receive a
hundred and thirty thousand dollar
payment but it was from Trump's lawyers
personal money and had nothing to do
with Donald Trump which is of course
ridiculous and I don't know anyone who
believed it but it's having major
implications and first of all there are
now legal implications possible beyond
the scope of this segment but if if
we're sort of determined to say if we
believe that the payoff was connected in
some way or another to the Trump
campaign this could be as illegal as
what former presidential candidate John
Edwards got in trouble for but that's
that's more of a legal question that
we're gonna leave for another story
okay the bigger immediate news is that
the porn star herself stormy Daniels who
previously had not been answering any
questions about this clearly because of
a nondisclosure agreement that she had
signed up until recently she had been he
at one point said there is no
non-disclosure agreement and there was a
note that supposedly she had written
although she went on the Jimmy Kimmel
program and Jimmy Kimmel pointed out
your signature on that note saying this
isn't a story looks very different than
your signature on this other document
and she didn't comment about that she
hasn't been commenting about anything
but now her attorneys are saying listen
Michael Cohen Trump's lawyer violated
the non-disclosure agreement by saying
she was paid a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars that means she is no
longer bound by the non-disclosure that
she previously denied even existed and
she's going to tell her story that's
what we're being told now it's going to
have to be litigated more than likely
but Daniels is saying that there there
is breach of contract here right that as
soon as Michael Cohen said I paid her a
hundred and thirty grand whether it's
true or not that she now can say
whatever she wants and the
non-disclosure is null and void and the
blast com is reporting that her legal
team
has notified Trump's legal team we're
letting you know stormy Daniels is now
free to say whatever she wants and I
hope we do get the full story from her
and just you wait for the smear campaign
that Trump is going to put together in
if this happens but I'm actually
thinking even further ahead than that I
hope that stormy Daniels sues Cohen for
violating the non-disclosure agreement
and if she did then we would get a
chance to see the document she signed
yeah which I assure you is a fascinating
and compelling document there's probably
two ways that this could go one is it's
written off as tabloid gossip Trump
calls it fake news and it blows over
because we know who Trump is and this
isn't like it's out of character for him
okay
the other is that we realize this is a
clear campaign finance violation and the
public seems to care all of a sudden
about Trump's infidelities although
actually is a big controversy yes it's
possible that Trump fists might all of a
sudden decide that this is the straw
that broke the camel's back and we
actually see action around this and
remember Trump hires the best people but
his own lawyer who arranged one hundred
and thirty thousand dollar payoff could
end up getting sued for violating the
deal he himself struck for Trump
presumably to protect his client I mean
you can't you you really can't write
this stuff and now let's get back to
that other thing right the legality of
the payment Michael Cohen is trying to
remove Trump from this entirely by
saying I personally paid stormy Daniels
one hundred and thirty thousand dollars
of my own money I've not been reimbursed
that's it
the problem is that researchers have
already found an LLC that was created to
issue this payment and number two they
found a hundred and thirty thousand
dollar payment from the Trump campaign
to Trump properties now it could be a
coincidence right because there are
payments that have been tracked down
that are exactly a hundred and thirty
thousand and a little bit more and a
little bit less so it could be
completely unrelated but you can be damn
sure that not only should this be looked
into I hope that Robert Muller now is
also looking into this and how how wild
is it that special prosecutor Robert
Muller's investigation might now include
looking at the legality of hush money
paid to porn stars by the sitting
president of the United States three
years ago you wouldn't have believed it
two years ago you probably wouldn't have
believed it but now it's reality yeah it
sounds pretty stormy to me yes very very
good and check off the puns for the day
and we will I met my quota move on to
the next story now that Pat's quota has
been met